je m'appelle johnny mars johnny max
comme beaucoup de chauffeurs cumule deux
métiers il est aussi photographe quand
il est au volant
son appareil photo est toujours prêt
[Musique]
les chauffeurs sont des indépendants
sous contrat lorsqu'ils obtiennent leur
permis ils sont leur propre patron
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux dans ce
métier c'est ce qui attire tant de
candidats
bref daoud elle lui et comédien il
conduit un taxi pour payer son loyer et
arrondir ses fins de mois
il loue son taxi à la semaine et le
partage avec un ami pour le faire rouler
24 heures sur 24
donc je m'apprête à payer ma location
hebdomadaire
cette semaine c'est 1250 dollars
les gens qui travaillent dans les
garages ne sont pas vraiment sympa
chaleureux où charmant ils sont méchants
et désagréable ils n'en veulent qu'à
votre argent ce j'ai travaillé avec des
garages où on me faisait attendre trois
heures trois heures et demie pour une
voiture
et puis il fallait être sympa avec la
personne qui s'occupait d'attribuer les
voitures lui donner quelques dollars de
plus et même ça ça ne marchait pas
[Musique]
normalement je travaille au minimum
douze heures par jour
l'intérêt de louer mon propre véhicule
choisir les horaires durant lesquels je
travaille les chauffeurs de taxi sont le
plus souvent indépendants individualiste
solitaire mais ce sont aussi des
explorateurs conduire un taxi c'est la
meilleure façon de découvrir new york
tous les jours je découvre quelque chose
que je n'ai jamais vu auparavant
diallo amadou vient du sénégal
il trouve que la police surveille à un
peu trop les taxis à new york qu'elle
est parfois un peu trop présente
[Musique]
mais en chauffeur expérimenté diallo
s'est déjoué les pièges les occidentaux
n'en obtient de police comme un faux
taxi mais comment peut-on reconnaître un
faux taxi d'un vrai normalement oui un
vrai taxi a le même numéro sur le toit
sur le medalion et sur la plaque
minéralogique
les deux produits plus de 600000
personnes utilisent chaque jour les
taxis new yorkais
même s'il est prisonnier de sa capsule
jaune le kbe soi-disant solitaire
rencontre beaucoup de monde je travaille
surtout deux jours à manhattan
on a affaire à des new york et qui vont
travailler rentrer chez eux ils vont
faire du shopping ou bien des touristes
qui visitent réveil j'ai sûrement eu
plus de 2000 clients dans mon taxi et
j'en ai eu que 2 qu'il n'était pas des
gens vraiment vraiment sympa je nous
vois un peu comme les psychologues du
monde parfois on est six colloques
parfois on est politicien à certaines
occasions gynécologue
la plupart des gens pensent bon je suis
dans ce taxi pour une moyenne de je
crois que la durée moyenne est de moins
de 10 minutes et que la course moyenne
de 8 ou 9 dollars et ils pensent qu'ils
ne reverront jamais le chauffeur de taxi
donc ils ouvrent leur coeur en nous
racontant des choses que parfois il ne
raconterai pas nos proches
il faut mais il n'ya pas que les
passagers qui s'énerve dans le trafic
je suis pressé dégage trou du cul